- All right well I
understand that you have
a new addition to your family, right?
- [Jo] Winston, unbelievable.
The cutest.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
Are you kidding me, look
at that, look at his eyes.
- [Kelly] Are they like
a green or a blue, what?
- They're hazel, they're like mine.
- Me too, I'm hazel.
- So get close.
- Yeah get close.
- Get close.
- Get so close.
(laughing)
I love Winston, so did you name him
after anyone special?
- I will tell you this, like, you know,
my son's mommy and I, we're not together,
we are divorced, but the best of friends.
- Oh that's so good.
- Yeah, so she's been actually staying
with me this whole time during this--
- Wow.
- Yeah.
Because you now they
said social distancing
and it scared me and I was like,
well if she's not gonna be with us,
then she's not gonna be
able to come visit Jo
or if he stays with her than I'm not gonna
be able to visit him.
- You thought
of the kids first, that's great.
- Yeah so I was just like, "Stay with us,
let's just stay at my house all together."
And she hasn't left.
(laughing)
- She's like hanging out, she's like,
"Mmm, nah, this is nice."
- No she's great.
- [Kelly] Here's a mask.
- No, she's great.
And that's another thing I will say
about this pandemic, it
has brought us together
and you know, yeah, we're not together
but the family was strong.
Like we, you know we were
there for Jo together.
- I think it's pretty cool
to show that yeah, that for your kid
you're capable of doing that.
- It was a beautiful thing and that's why
we got the dog.
That's why we got the dog.
The dog just brought joy to us
and it was just like we were,
there was times where
we so dark in the house
just mentally.
- Animals, man, yeah.